comedian Bill Cosby is heading back to
court today for a pre-trial hearing in
his sexual assault case
Cosby's first trial you may recall ended
in a hung jury last year the jury failed
to reach a unanimous decision about the
alleged assault of a former Temple
University employee and a constant back
in 2004 a judge will hear arguments this
week about the prosecution's request to
let 19 other Cosby accusers testify in
the retrial CBS legal analyst her name
is Ricky Clement is here and joins us at
the table
nice to see you Ricky Clayman thank you
so this trial is about one case one
woman how can the prosecution justify
what's their argument for saying listen
you need to hear from the other 19
accusers the general rule of law is
prior bad acts
that's uncharged misconduct other
allegations that haven't been proven
those acts are not admissible but there
are certain recognized exceptions to the
rule in law school we call them the
mimic exceptions it's a mnemonic device
one of the Em's
is mistake so what the government wants
to do is say look Bill Cosby knew that
he drugged Andrea constant because he
also drugged these other women and then
took sexual advantage of them so we show
an absence of a mistake or the
government says it's a common scheme or
plan it's a signature he had one mo if
you will and that's why we should let
these other accusers in what do you
think the judge will do about I think
the defense who has a good argument for
the judge both practicality and
practicality as well as in law in law
it's really simple
look we tried the case on the evidence
we don't try the case on evidence of
people's character or propensity to act
this is one woman one act and that the
judge ruled that way before only one and
he let one other accuser in and he
should keep his ruling but let's look at
practicality practicality the defense is
going to need a continuance to
investigate any other women and find out
the basis of their charges these are
20-30 years old
and finally judge doesn't only want a
continuance he doesn't want a 19 week
trial
Bill Cosby denies all the charges as
lawyers obviously denied they they've
asked for a dismissal on what grounds
and
it's a very fascinating motion and the
judge I think will give the defense an
evidentiary hearing the defense says
look it's not within the statute of
limitations this is too late and we can
prove it with phone records we can prove
it with Bill Cosby's travel records the
case absolutely should be thrown out and
he also has a new powerhouse attorney
bricky Kleeman thank you so much for
joining us